there was nothing Raquel could have said
back to her because she just
assassinated her every time the
Vanderpump Rules cast filmed their
highly anticipated reunion last week
following the news that Tom Sandoval
cheated on his partner of nine years
Ariana Maddox with their co-star Raquel
Levis how did that situation change how
you feel about Raquel oh my opinion of
her couldn't be lower now Sheena Shea
and Lala Kent are giving fans a little
insight into what went down when Ariana
confronted Raquel with Bravo cameras
rolling during this week's episode of
deer media Shenanigans with Sheena Shea
the reality stars praise Ariana for
being a boss I thought Ariana handled
herself so well like she sat back looked
insanely hot and amazing
and just sliced with her words so good
it was beautiful to watch I know of
course fans of the show and fellow Bravo
Liberties have been quick to support
Ariana like real housewives of Potomac
star can distillered Ariana girl I can't
cuss on E.T but bleep that bleep okay
you can do better and while Vanderpump
alums Jax Taylor and Brittany Cartwright
haven't been on the show for the past
two seasons they're still good friends
with most of the cast and have been in
touch with Ariana since Scandal first
erupted I've checked in on Ariana a
couple times I know that she hasn't been
alone for a second so that was good as
for how Raquel handled the reunion well
according to Sheena and Lala the fact
that she had not a single tear No
Remorse she sat at the reunion and did
not shed one tear no I know she actually
smiled which echoes Jackson Britney told
E.T about Tom this isn't just that I
hooked up with somebody there's lack of
empathy there it was like a premeditated
situation Sheena also recalls the night
she learned about Raquel and Tom's
Affair after filming Watch What Happens
live with Andy Cohen together I'm just
trying to live my life and I'm sorry if
that offends people but it's not going
to stop me from doing what I want to do
he was like watching a joke not believe
that and that's how she was that night
it was just like oops slept with him for
seven months following that night Raquel
filed a restraining order against Sheena
claiming she struck her a claim Sheena
denies no I did not punch her as we've
established I can't really form a fist
with these nails scientifically
impossible with those Nails exactly and
on Wednesday Raquel and her attorney
didn't show up to court for their
hearing so the judge dismissed the
restraining order I honestly hope I
never have to see her again because I
have nothing to even say to her face at
this point I've said everything I wanted
to say at the reunion fans will have
have to wait and see what Sheena had to
say the reunion is set to air in June
but in the meantime fans can watch all
the drama unfold as season 10 plays out
this is a full-blown love affair I wish
we both would have tried harder you
don't deserve one [__] tear of mine
you want anything for you to die
foreign